vi parlerò di ricerca clinica ma non dal
punto di vista mio di scienziata per me
le vere protagoniste della ricerca sono
le persone Infatti quella clinica è la
ricerca medica che coinvolge
direttamente le persone con lo scopo di
aumentare la conoscenza sulle malattie e
arrivare a curarle o a mitigarne gli
effetti e fra le tantissime persone che
ho incontrato vi racconto la storia di
due Alberto quella di Alberto e quella
di Kate Alberto otto anni fa quando
aveva 62 anni è venuto al nostro centro
di neurologia cognitiva
nell'ospedale dove lavoro come neurologa
oltre che ricercatrice perché aveva
notato
di memoria non ricordava gli
appuntamenti lui era un architetto e poi
avevano notato che magari perdeva
pazienza facilmente con i suoi clienti
lui che era sempre stato gentile e
Galante e dopo avere misurato le sue
difficoltà
cognitive di memoria e anche i marcatori
di malattia nel suo liquido
cerebrospinale siamo arrivati alla
diagnosi di malattie d'alzheimer Allora
era ancora lieve infatti lui è riuscito
a continuare a lavorare per altri due
anni ed è mancato pochi mesi fa e lui è
stato il primo partecipante a uno studio
di ricerca clinica sull'epidemiologia
ovvero su quanto è frequente nella
popolazione della demenza giovanile che
poi abbiamo pubblicato l'anno scorso
dopo aver raccolto tanti altri dati
Kate Kate aveva 55 anni quando le odi
agnosticato la malattia di Alzheimer e
lei era una ex ballerina bellissima e
i suoi disturbi erano iniziati con
difficoltà a trovare le parole disturbi
del linguaggio oltre che difficoltà di
memoria è proprio l'altro giorno la
sorella cercando il mio indirizzo email
su internet mi ha scritto mi ha trovato
perché sono già poi tornata da diversi
anni Scusate l'avevo incontrata ad
Oxford da dieci anni fa circa e mi ha
trovato e mi ha scritto per dirmi che è
mancata a fine agosto io lo ricordo
benissimo perché era stato una
partecipante entusiasta ad uno studio
che facevamo appunto dieci anni fa ad
Oxford sull'utilizzo di tecniche
avanzate di risonanza per la diagnosi
precoce
E perché vi racconto vi parlo di queste
due persone Innanzitutto per dirvi che
non è vero che la malattia di Alzheimer
viene solo alle persone anziane noi
seguiamo tantissimi pazienti con demenza
De Giorgio giovanile cioè prima dei 65
anni ma poi ve ne parlo soprattutto
perché entrambi Alberto e Kate
diagnosticati con una malattia che a me
oggi è non curabile hanno sono stati
fieri di partecipare a studi di ricerca
clinica e con loro altrettanto Fieri e
coinvolti sono stati i loro familiari
entrambi Alberto Kate e i loro familiari
sapevano che la loro partecipazione a
questi studi non avrebbe cambiato la
loro prognosi Pensateci
lo hanno fatto perché hanno voluto dare
il contributo e sapevano che loro
contributo sarebbe valso per tantissimi
altri ne hanno colto il potere
moltiplicatore e rigenerante
di recente ho ricevuto un finanziamento
dal European il Consiglio Europeo per la
ricerca e ho avuto questo onore e Questo
progetto si focalizza
sullo studio di un sintomo particolare
che solo alcuni pazienti con la malattia
di Alzheimer non tutti presentano ed è
la non consapevolezza di malattia ovvero
una persona che ha ovvi disturbi a
carico di memoria o altre funzioni
cognitive che però è convinta di non
avere alcun problema alcuna difficoltà
noi neurologi lo chiamiamo con un nome
particolare hanno bisogno sia e ad oggi
non sappiamo
Perché alcuni pazienti alcune persone
affette da malattia ad Alzheimer lo
presentano e altre no
Certo è che quando presente la
nosognosia ha conseguenze pesanti per la
persona affetta perché magari non vuole
essere curata e anche per il familiare
perché immaginatevi come è difficile
prendersi cura di qualcuno che pensa di
non avere bisogno
oltre alla nosognosia questo progetto
quinquennale Si concentrerà anche su un
altro sintomo strano che viene solo in
alcune persone con la malattia di
Alzheimer non sempre e che è relato al
credenze che non trovano riscontro nella
realtà per esempio la persona è convinta
che il proprio partner abbia l'amante o
che i vicini di casa lo vogliano
derubare e si chiamano dei libri di
furto dell'iri di gelosia
quando presenti questi sintomi hanno
bisogno di venire sono causa di grande
angoscia per la persona affetta perché
non si sente creduta Nonostante sia
estremamente convinto della veridicità
di quello che pensa e per i familiari
per il partner per gli amici perché
vedono sfumarsi davanti agli occhi
l'essenza della persona che amano
per arrivare un giorno a curare questi
sintomi questo progetto Come impennare
in questo progetto Io e le mie colleghe
e proveremo a studiare i meccanismi
attraverso cui il cervello colpito da
una malattia
neurodegenerativa come la malattia di
Alzheimer genera queste credenze false e
cercheremo di capire se è un problema
del danno diretto quindi una perdita di
funzione oppure invece è un tentativo
che il cervello sano fa di risposta al
danno che nel tentativo di compensare
che però diventa aberrante
e oltre a farvi capire Ovviamente questi
meccanismi per per cercare di curare
magari addirittura prevenire un giorno
questi sintomi lo studio di questi
sintomi particolari anche apre una
finestra su quella che è una questione
che I filosofi e gli scienziati
dibattono da secoli che l'origine della
coscienza nel senso di consapevolezza
Infatti ciò che hai perso in una persona
che ha questi sintomi è la
consapevolezza di sé e della realtà è
ciò che definisce l'identità di quella
persona Quindi riusciamo a proteggerla
riusciamo a prevenire che venga
danneggiato
Sono domande importanti Oggi abbiamo
tecnologie che non avevamo 10 anni fa
che ci permettono di studiare il
funzionamento del cervello io in
particolare Mi occupo di risonanza
magnetica tecnica avanzata di questa
tecnica di questa risonanza che
permettono di guardare non solo la forma
del cervello ma anche il funzionamento e
si è visto per esempio che non è solo
importante la singola parte del cervello
che fa una specifica funzione ma è
altrettanto importante come diverse
parti del cervello comunicano fra di
loro come sono connesse si è visto
infatti che anche a riposo quando non
stiamo facendo nessun compito cognitivo
il nostro cervello ha alcune parti che
comunicano fra di loro molto più molto
che parlano molto di più rispetto ad
altre parti e le mappe che individuano
le parti del cervello che comunicano di
più si è visto essere diversamente
vulnerabili a diverse malattie
neurodegenerative e quindi pensiamo che
abbiano un ruolo specifico anche
l'origine dei sintomi Quindi abbiamo la
tecnologia abbiamo i finanziamenti
ottenuti con grandissima fatica e
perseveranza ma il mio il nostro lavoro
non potrebbe esserci senza le persone
perché la ricerca clinica si fa con
l'attiva partecipazione e il consenso
delle persone
per esempio nei nostri studi noi
reclutiamo direttamente dal nostro
centro di neurologia cognitiva le
persone che hanno determinate
caratteristiche ovviamente chiedendo
loro il consenso e spiegando che non c'è
alcun obbligo e che noi comunque le
continueremo a seguire dal punto di
vista clinico E insieme a loro nel caso
della demenza reclutiamo sempre anche un
partner di studio che è anche libero un
familiare qualcuno che conosci bene la
persona che possa rispondere a domande
su di essa e poi reclutiamo sempre anche
un gruppo di controllo che servirà per
fare i confronti
e sempre per darvi un esempio chiediamo
ai partecipanti di fare questionari Ma
poi anche di fare propri esami di
risonanza in cui a volte devono stare
semplicemente a riposo e non fare nulla
e li guardiamo appunto il funzionamento
a riposo ma altre volte invece chiediamo
loro di fare dei compiti proiettando
immagini su uno schermo che loro si
vedono quando sono dentro la macchina
dello scanner o immagini o frasi e in
base a quello che evoca questo compito
noi riusciamo andare a vedere proprio le
attivazioni quale aree si attivano in un
determinato compito e riusciamo a fare
poi il confronto con quello che succede
nel gruppo di controlli sani che hanno
fatto lo stesso compito
questo è una una parte tecnica del mio
lavoro ma ovviamente c'è molto di più ed
è un esempio perché ci sono tantissimi
altri tipi di ricerca clinica spesso
quelli coinvolgono anche l'utilizzo di
farmaci e sperimentazioni su farmaci ma
ve l'ho detto per darvi per darvi
un'idea di quella che è la ricerca
clinica cioè ricerca che davvero
coinvolgere persone affette o non
affette da una determinata condizione
che vogliamo studiare per cercare di
risolverla e curarla
e grazie alla ricerca clinica che
abbiamo ottenuto tutti i farmaci che
usiamo quotidianamente e tutti voi
potete diventare protagonisti di ricerca
clinica come partecipanti se affetti da
determinate patologie Come familiare o
come volontari sani
chi partecipa a uno studio di ricerca
clinica fa un atto di estrema generosità
perché non ci sono benefici se non
quello indiretto di essere magari
monitorati più frequentemente da noi
medici e ricercatori chi partecipa lo fa
per aiutare gli altri per contribuire a
qualcosa di grande
è un atto che permette alla persona
ammalata al suo familiare e a tutti noi
potenziali partecipanti di diventare
moltiplicatori di rigenerazione
[Applauso]